I can be your family you wouldn't be my
family you'd be my lady hey youtubers
it's Charlie welcome to my game of
Thrones Season 4 preview for Gendry even
though he's a relatively minor character
in A Song of Ice and Fire the HBO show
has really expanded as part a lot so
let's talk about where he's going in
season 4 and what's happening to his
character full disclosure this is the
part where I tell you spoilers for
everything that's happened on the show
so far and minor spoilers for book for
so if you haven't heard already the show
runners are changing a lot of things in
season 4 to just streamline the plot of
a song of ice and fire the characters
kind of jump around a lot of the story
jumps around and they're basically just
adapting it to make it a little more
linear for the show that means we're
going to lose some extra characters but
we're going to get more of people like
Gendry and people they want to keep on
the show remember how they gave Gendry
all of Erichs storm storylines so he's
basically a dragon stone right now where
season four is going to pick up each
season tends to pick up where the
previous season left off and gunnery can
either go one of two ways he can either
go back to King's Landing in the
crossroads or he can go to the east
which is basically where the eadric
storm storyline goes remember since he's
basically like eadric storm now from a
story standpoint it's totally possible
that he could end up in Essos let's talk
about the crossroads possibility first
so someone actually asked me in the
comments if I thought that he would go
back to the Brotherhood actually at the
time he asked me I wasn't so sure but
actually after reading some things about
Gendry storyline it kind of makes me
think that it's totally possible because
we know that brian is going to be on her
quest again in a song of ice and fire
ends up helping Brienne he basically
ends up saving her life though coming
back in season for our org and biter and
those two characters are pretty
important to Brienne's storyline Henry
ends up saving her from fighter at a
certain point while she's on her quest
and since we know that she's on her
quest obviously we know that scene is
probably going to end up happening since
Kendra's character has nowhere to go
it's totally possible from a story
standpoint that he could want to go back
to the crossroads and join the
Brotherhood again in the story they
actually night him so they kind of give
him a purpose the second possibility the
eadric storm ESO storyline is also very
possible because arias character ends up
going to the east at a certain point and
that might end up happening in season 4
so it's totally possible that there
could be a Gendry Arya reunion in the
east
some issues I have with that storyline
are as that Arya's character has some
really dramatic left turns that she
takes it gets really dark and it would
be really hard for her character to go
to that place with Gendry with one of
her really really good friends there
kendriya is actually kind of like a Jon
Snow replacement for aria there's also
some shipping going on but he's really
just a big brother proxy for her but let
me know what you think based on the
evidence we have two possibilities one
he could go back to the crossroads and
two he go to the east make sure to write
in the comments and we'll discuss if I
or if you have a competing theory be
sure to let us know too but my next game
of Thrones Season 4 preview will be
first or Davos the very person that put
him on that boat at the end of season 3
so many of you requested it and The
Onion Knight is actually a really really
interesting character be sure to
subscribe to get that video since
there's no sleepy hollow for about three
weeks it's on a break right now i might
post that video on monday don't forget
there's an hour-long special episode of
core tonight i'll be posting that video
right after the episode airs it's going
to be really exciting and on sunday is a
new episode of the walking dead as
always be sure to let me know what your
game of thrones season four theories are
and which characters you want to talk
about next and i'll be sure to add them
to my list thank you so much for
watching you guys in the meantime you
can click here to watch all my other
game of thrones season for previews and
you can click here to watch my latest
American Horror Story video that series
is totally off the rails awesome you
should check it out thanks for watching
see you guys then I procore high fives
you